[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas el reconocimiento de
la independencia de las regiones de
donny esquilu cannes que por parte del
presidente vladimir putin supone una
nueva escalada en las tensiones entre
rusia y occidente
además el kremlin ha ordenado el
despliegue de tropas a esa zona la otan
acusa a putin de estar ayudando un
conflicto y por ende los temores de una
guerra en moscú la unión de voluntarios
del donbass una organización de fuerzas
rusas que pelea desde el 2014 asegura
estar lista para combatir de la mano de
los separatistas del este de ucrania si
se les da la orden el siguiente es un
reportaje de nuestra corresponsal en el
terreno elena valuación
el supuesto enemigo está a la derecha y
entramos en contacto para repeler su
ataque estos hombres se presentan como
oficiales de reserva del ejército ruso
todos ellos han luchado en bombas
separatista en este bosque de la región
de moscú se preparan en tácticas de
combate
entrenamiento que su líder dimitri barón
considera rutinario pero en las
circunstancias actuales dicen estar
dispuestos a un enfrentamiento real
si es necesario nuestra unión de
voluntarios del donbass combatirá para
defender al pueblo ruso en el donbass y
por supuesto estos enfrentamientos no
serán útiles y espera que se produzca
pronto un escenario así
si puede imaginarse que con una escalada
como la que estamos viviendo esperamos
que ocurra porque
si defender al pueblo ruso en bombas una
retórica desplegada por rusia desde el
inicio del conflicto en esta región del
este de ucrania en moscú la organización
de combatientes rusos en bombas está
dirigida por alexander borodín es el
primer líder de la entidad separatista
que se autoproclamó república popular de
donets
rusia no podrá permanecer indiferente ni
eludir la intervención cuando se
produzca el genocidio del pueblo ruso de
bombas les recuerdo que desde el 2018
rusia distribuye pasa por que sean
bombas y hoy unas 800.000 personas que
viven allí son ciudadanos de rusia
según alexander borodín la guerra es ya
inevitable y de acuerdo a sus palabras
que hacen eco al kremlin la culpa es de
una ucrania colonizada por la otan y del
este de ucrania nos trasladamos aquí a
la capital el espectro de una guerra ha
reavivado los dolores del pasado
reciente fue en esta ciudad donde
comenzó y estalló lo que llevó a
conocerse como la revolución del maidán
en la que murieron unos 130
manifestantes y que terminó con las
salidas del presidente prorruso víctor
yanukóvich ocho años después los
familiares de las víctimas recordaron a
sus seres queridos en medio de los
temores de una eventual invasión rusa
informe de julian seguida y katrin
nuestra
[Música]
un momento de meditación en un contexto
de extrema tensión
muchos aquí perdieron a un familiar en
el levantamiento de maidán de 2014
presente en el homenaje el expresidente
petro poroshenko elegido tras ese
acontecimiento histórico apenas puede
creer que su país siga estando amenazado
creo que putin se ha vuelto
completamente loco esta es una fecha
simbólica para ucrania y después de ocho
años de conflicto corremos un gran
peligro por la incesante presión de
putin hoy estamos rodeados por el
ejército ruso
después de la misa juliá hace los
últimos preparativos para una marcha en
honor a los desaparecidos entre ellos
estaba su marido que murió tras ser
golpeado hasta la muerte
los ucranianos tienen buena memoria si
es necesario nos enfrentaremos al
agresor y este es rusia no lo
olvidaremos
cientos de manifestantes se dirigen a la
plaza de la independencia donde todo
comenzó
mientras que en kiev al y cada vez que
vuelve a la plaza de maidán símbolo de
resistencia para los ucranianos piensa
en los momentos vividos
primero fueron los días que pasaron
ayudando a los heridos de bala antes de
ir a luchar en el frente
y nuestro trabajo era atender a los
heridos que estaban cubiertos de sangre
se retorcían de dolor
poleo estoy listo para unirme a las
fuerzas armadas de nuevo ya ha
averiguado a donde tengo que ir para ser
desplegado en el frente y allí sabré
exactamente qué hacer
a pesar de las repetidas declaraciones
alarmistas de washington sobre una
posible invasión rusa los ucranianos no
están dispuestos a dejarse intimidar
según una encuesta reciente mientras que
el 60% de la población quiere que su
país entre en la otan
méxico es uno de los países más
peligrosos del mundo para ejercer el
periodismo en las últimas dos décadas
150 han sido los reporteros asesinados y
este 2022 arrancó con una ola de
violencia que se ha cobrado la vida de
al menos 5 comunicadores es el
recrudecimiento de un fenómeno que ha
obligado a muchos de ellos al
desplazamiento forzoso mario' carbonell
nos trae la historia desde ciudad de
mexico
la periodista cynthia valdez sufrió
amenazas de muerte de un grupo criminal
en su estado natal sinaloa el mecanismo
del gobierno de protección para
periodistas la traslado a ciudad de
méxico y le dio refugio tres años
después ella decidió volver a su lugar
de origen a ejercer nuevamente su labor
a pesar de sentir que las autoridades la
abandonaron en este proceso se
estableció un plan de retorno en
conjunto con la ciudad pero sin embargo
hasta la fecha no se ha acordado ninguna
medida me dejaron en la total
indefensión al perder yo mis medidas de
seguridad porque ni siquiera tengo un
monitoreo ya de policía federal ni de
ninguna institución de seguridad en
sinaloa aula saucedo de artículo 19
advierte que las medidas del gobierno
para proteger a periodistas en peligro
se limitan a un enfoque reactivo que no
hay prevención en las medidas que se dan
yo te doy una medida de protección pero
que al yo no investigar estas amenazas
de dónde vienen no generarte condiciones
para para aumentar los costos de que te
agredan te van a seguir agrediendo un
mar bello es otro periodista en riesgo
que debió abandonar su natal guerrero
tras ser víctima de secuestro y amenazas
lleva cuatro años en un refugio en
ciudad de méxico y su única medida de
protección es un botón de pánico
esto nada más para que sepan dónde
quedaste
realmente de que aquello le apachurro
aquí el botón y se dan cuenta ya me
mataron
al sufrir la agresión tenía ocho años
trabajando de manera formal en un
periódico de zihuatanejo hoy no logra
conseguir empleo y una de las
consecuencias de ser desplazado y de
estar bajo el mecanismo es que pierdes
entre otras cosas tu vida laboral cintia
y omar tuvieron la fortuna de ser
protegidos a tiempo la misma suerte no
la tuvieron los cinco periodistas
asesinados entre el 15 de enero y el 10
de febrero de 2022 con lo que ya suman
29 en el sexenio actual el 90 por ciento
de los crímenes contra periodistas en el
país quedan impunes la industria
aeronáutica mundial está bajo presión
tiene el reto de reducir su huella de
carbono y llegar a cero emisiones para
el año 2050 un verdadero reto para una
nueva generación de ingenieros para
quienes los temas ambientales ahora
forman parte fundamental de sus estudios
sophie bolis nos trae el siguiente
reporte desde toulouse la capital
europea del agro
es una de las escuelas más prestigiosas
de europa en el campo de la ingeniería
aeroespacial 1900 alumnos de la escuela
siguieron un curso tradicional que les
garantizaba un trabajo en la industria
aeronáutica tan pronto como se graduarán
hoy los programas han cambiado y ahora
abordan el impacto de la industria de la
aviación en el medio ambiente diría que
desde hace tres o cuatro años realmente
ha habido una conciencia y movilización
mucho más fuerte por parte de los
estudiantes en estos temas de transición
energética y la lucha contra el cambio
climático en el campus el tema del medio
ambiente siempre está presente esta
clase se enfoca en las nuevas
generaciones de drones que usan
hidrógeno como fuente de energía
alternativa por otra parte los
estudiantes están trabajando en un
proyecto que se centra en la reducción
de energía y que incluso podría
aplicarse directamente a la industria
aeronáutica en el futuro creo que todos
los temas ambientales son muy
importantes para los futuros ingenieros
en realidad ahora estamos trabajando en
el tema de la descarbonización de la
industria aeronáutica los
aproximadamente 200 investigadores en el
lugar están adoptando nuevos métodos de
trabajo tienen una sensibilidad mucho
más fuerte por los temas ambientales se
nota muy bien en su relación con la
tecnología y también en su forma de
abordar diversos temas
si bien aún es difícil integrar estas
prestigiosas escuelas aeronáuticas
alrededor de un tercio de los
estudiantes finalmente optan por irse a
otros sectores porque consideran que los
desafíos relacionados con el medio
ambiente son mucho más importantes
decidido ya que si tomar el camino del
emprendimiento para montar mi negocio y
enfocarme en el impacto ambiental a
pactó un modelo en las escuelas
aeronáuticas cuando se impartieron los
primeros cursos sobre temas ambientales
hace 8 años había pocos aficionados hoy
estos cursos son obligatorios
la crisis ambiental nos lleva a buscar
alternativas al plástico que sean
sostenibles es el caso de la fibra de
yute gracias a su clima húmedo india ha
sido un productor histórico de esta
planta que se utiliza para la producción
de bolsas biodegradables y que han
llegado incluso a hacer presencia en las
pasarelas de marcas de alta costura el
yute vive un verdadero auge y el país
espera poder sacar provecho de este
prometedor mercado el siguiente es un
reportaje de matisse kusa hizo
en esta fábrica de calcuta estos
trabajadores producen un material ahora
apreciado en todo el mundo élfico
la fibra aquí acaba de ser cosechada
y se cortan de los campos y luego se
extrae su fibra del tallo una vez están
secas y se convierten en paquetes de
fique este establecimiento transforma el
material de fique en hilo y
posteriormente en tela desde 1877 luego
se vende para la fabricación de bolsas
industriales destinadas al mercado local
indio pero hoy la función de esta
fábrica está a punto de dar un nuevo
giro
ahora estamos viendo un gran cambio en
el mercado estamos recibiendo más
clientes ahora tenemos una demanda de 20
contenedores cada mes para exportación
india es el mayor productor mundial de
fibra de fique se ha cultivado durante
siglos en sus humedales orientales con
más de un millón de toneladas de fique
vendidas en 2020 la industria está
experimentando un nuevo auge el fique es
atractivo por sus cualidades
biodegradables y su bajo impacto
ambiental
el fic es un producto que puede
reemplazar el uso sintético y plástico y
también está dando beneficios
ambientales mitigar el efecto
invernadero y reducir el co2 en la
atmósfera es realmente oro para la india
podemos ganar mucho dinero con ello
a mano
calcuta es el epicentro de la producción
mundial esta fábrica produce más de 3
millones de sacos de fique al año
principalmente para exportar a grandes
marcas internacionales algunas de estas
bolsas están pintadas a mano pero muchas
otras se decoran con máquinas
automáticas gracias al éxito mundial de
los sacos de fique la empresa ha podido
modernizar su fábrica así como las
condiciones laborales de sus empleados
m
entonces estas bolsas las estamos
haciendo para la tienda café podemos ver
aquí en india que muchas empresas están
ampliando sus capacidades modernizando
sus plantas debido a la gran demanda
porque si no seguimos modernizándonos
retrocederemos
para 2024 el mercado de bolsas de fin
que podría tener un valor de 2.500
millones de euros e incluso puede
convertirse en una alternativa viable al
plástico gracias por acompañarnos en
esta nueva emisión de corresponsales nos
damos cita la próxima semana siga con
más información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]